i think two of the reasons uh that just
gonna stick with me a month before the
belfast good friday agreement at the
height of these really really difficult
negotiations
two young men in a little village called
points pass were murdered by loyalist
terrorists great friends across the
divide
philip allen and damien traynor
and sheamus
malin and david trimble
went together
to see the families and to express their
condolences and that became the spirit
of the 1998 agreement of that kind of
consensual
politics of realizing that although we
were two tribes we could come together
and make one
northern ireland one community uh
working together
and then later after the good friday
agreement was signed the worst atrocity
of the troubles you remember was the
umber bomb
in 1998 late 1898 and
three young boys three young catholics
from bronchrana in donegal in the irish
republic
were killed
murdered
and david went to their funeral mass and
maybe to many of your audience that
doesn't sound like a big deal but david
was a member of the orange order and you
were not allowed to participate in a
catholic
church service
uh and david saw
that there was something beyond his
cherished membership of the orange order
about serving the people
and he went
to the funeral mass for those three
children
and i remember as a journalist going to
the first minister's office a couple of
days later to interview him for ulster
television where i worked
and i'm not proud of this but i'm not
ashamed of this because i am of northern
ireland i've always lived here and i
cherish the place
i cried
i was so proud
so very very proud
of david triple